[Applaudissements]
la chaîne pour elle tous les soirs pour
fermement tout temps la même question
tant pis si je me rends moi je le vend
toujours parler derrière mon dos ça ne
m'intéresse pas au lieu de parler sur
moi allez plutôt vous instruire louga
journée médian nouvelle merde je pense à
demain je suis pas lesbienne grandi en
me fait peur mon futur est trompeur il
exprime un peu nos sentiments c'est ce
que retient
ban
la vie
moi ça m'énerve et gens qui font des
différences pourquoi s'attacher aux
apparences moi j'aime tout nous et trois
chocolats macarons bariolés alors
pourquoi des pays mais toute l'humanité
[Applaudissements]
tout ça c'était des mensonges dans mon
dos ça n'a pas de fin et tout n'est que
de la tromperie quand vous dit je t'aime
thd manceaux se sont juste des mots mais
aucune parole pourquoi tant de haine sur
terre pourquoi elles peuvent être en
colère même contre sa propre mère
pourquoi tant de guerres toutes ces
bombes qui créent des cratères
mais pas que dans la terre mais aussi
dans les coeurs car il ya des gens qui
meurent
[Applaudissements]
waouh
à